so der herzen gewählt zuerst habe ich
niemanden aperitif sehr gern für meine
frau prosecco und ich nehme an martini
prosecco für die dame für den herrn
einen martin kommt sofort erhält
entschuldigung vielleicht für mich doch
lieber aperol spritz und keinen martini
einen aperol spritz der prosecco für die
dame bleibt ja selbstverständlich
wobei prosecco passte vielleicht nicht
so gut zum fisch oder höher doch
eigentlich schon eher wissen sie schon
was sie essen möchten ja für meine frau
bitte ein kaltes resort ein kalbs resort
um das eigentlich kein fisch ist von
daher passt prosecco doch und ich nehme
die gebratenen zander gebratenen zander
eine gute wahl salzkartoffeln oder
kroketten dazu kam ist aber sicher auch
so vielleicht doch lieber salzkartoffeln
doch lieber die salzkartoffeln zu
trinken bitte zum trinken wein oder bier
vielleicht für die damian meinung für
mich hier ein bier für den herrn ein
kleines bier ein kleines kaltes bier
aber vielleicht nicht zu kalt vielleicht
lieber so raumtemperatur
natur und der wein weißt du ich nehme
vielleicht doch auch lieber zweimal wein
weiß oder rot rot weiß roten vielleicht
nicht mehr an bord oder merlot in rio
hatte einen review eine gute wahl ja
mein hobby hat einfach ein sicheres
händchen
obwohl darüber vielleicht nicht so gut
zum zander passt mir nehmen wir doch ein
weißwein zweimal weißwein darf sein
frischer rieslings an frische riesling
sehr gut es ist für mich ein riesling
und zum tor vielleicht doch eher einmal
rot einmal weißwein also dann haben wir
für die dame des kalbs risotto mit dem
rio für den herrn das zanderfilet mit
salzkartoffeln einem studium riesling
dazu und als aperitif aber prosecco und
einmal abgespeist zusammengehört oder
dann klar wie handy doch liebe gern an
martini doch lieber einen martini und
pommes zum zander keine salzkartoffeln
nein keine salzkartoffeln über das
gefühl sie hören nicht so wichtig zu
keine salzkartoffeln sondern gomez
thomas kann ich nur empfehlen ja sie
irgendwie empfehlungen irgendwie was
durch das alles nicht zusammen
jetzt machen wir so sie geben uns bitte
noch mal die karte und wir fangen noch
mal ganz von vorne an was das kommt
überhaupt nicht in frage
wir kürzen das ganze jetzt ab sie und
ihre werte gab ihm bekommen von mir ein
paar wiener der studie dazu gibt es aber
gerade und eine abwärtswelle
vielen dank für die bestellung
das klingt doch eigentlich gar nicht so
schlecht aber bitte die wiener würstchen
mit viel senf und das glas mehrweg bitte
kein kraut gern
oder doch mit kraut